[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
hardware season aka
techtober continues with a new
smartphone again this is our first look
and impressions of the razer phone 2.
now i know a lot of people were
interested in this phone i found the
first one uh somewhat of a mixed bag i
definitely had my complaints about it
but it was promising and it had some
unique unmatched features like a 120
hertz display now this year those
features are still here and they're
definitely still unmatched but they've
made a number of improvements and tweaks
and upgrades towards one thing and that
is to make this second generation razer
phone
a little bit more friendly like a normal
everyday flagship not just a gaming
phone now they're not going all the way
to full-on bezel-less notched all the
way to the edge 2018 design no no but
pretty much every little change and
every tweak they've made in this phone
is targeted towards that appealing to
more of the masses with a phone that can
actually be used every day that happens
to have a couple advantages for gaming
so here's what's new first thing you've
probably noticed already is the glass
back i'd say this is the biggest outside
change on the razer phone we all
remember the first one soft touch back
sort of like that next bit robin it came
from well the shape of the sequel is all
still the same still very boxy and
square but now you have a glass back
which enables wireless charging which
this phone now has and then not to be
outdone by asus they also have now a
glowing light up razer logo on the back
of this phone controllable by software
of course and with rgb and razer told me
you'll even be able to use this as a
notification led so if you get a tweet
for example it'll glow blue if you get
an email it'll glow red green for phone
calls etc that's actually pretty sick
but of course you can turn it off all
the way if you don't want it
it is pretty faint to begin with
especially in this brightly lit
environment but it's there it's also now
ip67 certified which the first one
wasn't but doing this turned out to be a
big deal for razer phone because the
huge speakers had to be water sealed but
still keep their massive sound that's
the whole reason they're there so that
was a challenge for them as you may know
waterproofing a phone 100 of the time
has a hit on the speakers when you go
from a non-waterproof phone to a
waterproof phone you always notice that
samsung's phones all used to have better
speakers many years ago they
waterproofed them and now not so much
htc had those massive boom sound
speakers those front firing stereo
monsters but none of those phones were
ip rated it's just a big deal putting a
water tight diaphragm in front of a
speaker driver so my big question when i
saw the second one was would the razer
phone 2 being waterproof make it lose
its amazing speakers i love so much
about it after hearing them
i actually don't think so so to be clear
they're still very loud and very hard to
block with your fingers that's what it's
all about i'd say they probably have a
little bit of a lower peak loudness than
before but quality is great and they
definitely didn't distort at high
volumes from my brief listening test so
that's good to see
and up front there's also a slightly
brighter 5.7 inch 120 hertz ips lcd
display the only one in a phone again
this year 2560 by 1440 resolution but
yeah it is now up to 645 nits
basically brighter than last year but
still not quite as bright as the 60hz
oleds and all these mainstream flagships
that's the trade-off for the ultra
smooth frame rate and then also they
specifically addressed some of my
biggest complaints in my review with the
first razer phone first off the camera
there are two new sony sensors on the
back they're both now 12 megapixel
sensors one standard one with optical
image stabilization and one telephoto
without it these will be worth testing
to see how far they've come but they
seem pretty proud of them and they've
also now switched to a new vibration
motor so i did kind of really hate on
the vibration motor in my unit last year
this one's entirely different that's a
good look you got a snapdragon 845
inside still eight gigs of ram
still a four thousand milliamp hour
battery still has expandable storage
still no headphone jack still the side
power slash fingerprint reader button
and the little nub volume buttons on the
side from the original next bit design
and still a light skin on top of android
8.1 waiting for android pie eventually
someday who knows when that'll come
but little bit of green accents tossed
in there plus a couple features
specifically for improving gaming and
changing your rgb lights on the back of
course so yeah it's a nice little mixed
bag of improvements i'm interested uh at
this point they're consciously trying
not to just call it a gaming phone but
more of like a media and gaming flagship
and i think those are good moves to take
so what do you think i mean if you're on
team no notch then this will definitely
be one of your last available options if
you're on team i hate every thousand
dollar flagship phone because they're
not worth that much this will also be
one of your latest options but also one
of your best so let me know what you
think
either way that's been your first
impressions thanks for watching talk to
you guys in the next one
peace